hallo leute ich bin kari und ich bin ihr
luschen grund zusammen mit manuel easy
und einigen anderen freunden produzieren
wir jede woche videos und einen podcast
zum deutsch lernen
in diesem video zeigen wir euch mal wie
wir unsere videos und unseren podcast
produzieren und nehmen euch mit auf eine
kleine tour hinter die kulissen von easy
german als erstes möchten wir euch
zeigen wie wir unsere videos produzieren
unsere straßen interviews sind
tatsächlich das format mit dem easy
german bekannt geworden ist tatsächlich
gehen wir fast jede woche hier in berlin
manchmal auch in anderen städten auf die
straße und interviewen menschen später
bekommen diese videos dann untertitel in
deutsch und in englisch und das ist dann
eben eine ganz besondere möglichkeit für
euch die deutsche sprache und auch
deutschland kennenzulernen
für mich ist dieses reden mit den
menschen auf der straße ein traumberuf
sein wie eine jagd ist würde wie
einsammeln ein hobby ich treffe menschen
ich rede mit den menschen ich lerne
ständig neue typen von menschen kennen
und das ist einfach spannend und jedes
mal spannend als nächstes zeigen wir
euch mal wie wir den easy german podcast
produzieren in unserem podcast reden
manuel und ich jede woche über ganz
verschiedene themen über unseren alltag
zum beispiel oder über das leben in
deutschland im moment produzieren wir
unseren podcast meistens von zu hause
aber wir haben auch ein kleines studio
im norden von berlin und da seht ihr uns
jetzt
[Musik]
hallo manuell hallo karin navi gibt es
ja heute sehr gut wie geht es dir
ich freue mich dass wir heute mal mit
einem studio sind ich mich ja auch ich
habe einige themen vorbereitet
oh ja ich nicht was mittlerweile ist die
amish wieder zurück zu hause und wir
zeigen euch jetzt mal wie die
postproduktion von unseren videos
abläuft
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt dabei das video fertig zu
machen also ich bin bei dem letzten
schritt davor haben wir das video
geschnitten und verbessert und dann
haben wir das video an jemanden
geschickt er uns das transkribiert so
alles aufschreibt was gesprochen wird in
dem video
dann haben wir das mal jemanden
geschickt ihr das für uns übersetzt
und wenn wir dann das alles zurück haben
dann produziert karl jedoch die sub
deutlich setzte die sub battles rein und
guck doch mal ob es ja vielleicht doch
irgendwo fehler gibt in dem video kabel
guckt auch nochmal wir versuchen
wirklich fehlerlos zu arbeiten und dann
ist das video heute fertig und wird in
eine stunde glaube ich in anderthalb
stunden publizierter zeit für einen
ortswechsel jetzt besuchen wir mal easy
easy ist meine schwester und ihr kennt
sie sicherlich aus vielen super easy
german videos sie ist jedoch nicht nur
vor der kamera bei easy germany dabei
sondern auch seit vielen jahren fester
bestandteil des teams hinter der kamera
sie kümmert sich unter anderem um unsere
community und arbeitet auch an
zusätzlichen materialien zum deutsch
lernen
[Musik]
hallo ich bin i see ich arbeite hier in
brighton england ihr seht es ein
bisschen im hintergrund und wie kann ich
schon erzählt hat produziere ich einige
super easy german folgen vielleicht habt
ihr schon einige gesehen in denen ich
dabei bin und kümmere mich auch in
unsere community und ebenfalls erstelle
ich unsere wöchentlichen work stets zu
den episoden und das möchte ich euch
jetzt mal zeigen also zu begehen lege
ich immer zu dem aktuellen video eine
vokabel ist dann das seht ihr hier das
sind die vokabeln und dann schaue ich
mir an welches thema aus der episode ist
relevant für deutsch lerne und womit
wozu kann ich übung erstellen hier haben
wir natürlich ein ganz spezifisches
thema fragen auf deutsch stellen und
dann lege ich immer circa sechs übungen
für unsere mitglieder an
bei easy habt ihr jetzt gerade schon
gesehen dass wir ganz unterschiedliche
materialien zum deutsch lernen anbieten
tatsächlich produzieren wir all unsere
videos und auch unsere podcast episoden
umsonst und wie ihr wisst könnt ihr
diese auf youtube und in allen gängigen
podcast apps finden für alle von euch
die noch intensiver mit uns lernen
möchten bieten wir jedoch auch
zusatzmaterialien an
so könnt ihr zum beispiel zu unseren
videos transkripte vokabel listen und
interaktive übungen bekommen
zu unserem podcast könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch transkript einen
interaktiven transkript player und eine
vokabel hilfe direkt in eurer podcast
app bekommen wenn ihr ein mitglied
werden möchte dann könnt ihr das tun auf
bachelor dort vom isi german wir
organisieren diese mitgliedschaften über
eine seite die petrol rest habt ihr
vielleicht schon mal gehört und dort
gibt es dann auch verschiedene levels
und je nachdem was ihr bekommen möchte
und was ihr ausgeben möchtet könnt ihr
euch dort für eine mitgliedschaft
entscheiden
wir freuen uns auf jeden fall wenn ihr
dabei seid als mitglied denn
als mitglied bekommt ihr nicht nur viele
zusätzliche lernmaterialien sondern
unterstützt auch unser projekt denn
unser projekt finanziert sich
tatsächlich hauptsächlich aus diesem
mitgliedschaften als nächstes schalten
wir nochmals so manuel manuel ist
mittlerweile zu hause und schneidet dort
an der nächsten podcast episode so ich
bin mittlerweile zu hause und habe die
podcast episode von heute geschnitten
danach hat es da die bei uns mitarbeitet
ein komplettes transkript geschrieben
und vokabeln aus der episode übersetzt
damit unsere mitglieder mit lesen können
und so kamen lernen können und ich werde
die episode jetzt veröffentlichen und
dann habt ihr eine neue episode auf
eurem handy
[Musik]
das war unser behind the scenes video
wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen und
jetzt wisst ihr ein bisschen besser wäre
eigentlich sind und was wir machen wenn
ihr regelmäßig unsere videos guckt oder
unseren podcast nützlich findet zum
deutsch lernen dann würden wir uns
wahnsinnig freuen wenn ihr ein mitglied
von easy german werden würdet dann
bekommt ihr viele zusätzliche
materialien um euer deutsch noch weiter
zu verbessern und ihr unterstützt auch
gleichzeitig unsere arbeit hier oder
hier blenden wir jetzt unsere passion
seite ein oder hier unten findet ihr sie
in der infobox dort könnt ihr die
verschiedenen levels sehen und ein
mitglied werden
danke für eure unterstützung und alle
die bereits dabei sind und bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]